لنبدأ بوزارة الرياضة
لأننا هنا اليوم أه ما نوع
المحادثات التي أجريتها مع صاحب
السمو الملكي أه والموضوع الذي
ناقشته ، شكرًا لك وقد كنت كذلك في
أول زيارة لي للسعودية وأنا  لقد
تأثرت كثيرًا بالدولة
والشعب ، وفي الواقع اليوم في وزارة الرياضة
كنت أسمع عن
الخطط المستقبلية لاستراتيجية الرياضة لعام 2030
والتي تتوافق بالطبع مع
الرؤية وهي كل ما
يحدث هنا سواء كان ذلك
فريق كرة القدم النسائي ولرؤية النساء يلعبن
كرة السلة وكرة القدم ،
سأشاهد الفوز ألعب كرة القدم الآن
والنساء اللواتي شاهدت للتو فتاة تبلغ من العمر ست سنوات
في الكاراتيه هي مجرد آه ظاهرة
لم يظن أحد أننا سنراها
في هذا اليوم عندما كانت النساء يشاركن
في رياضات كهذه وما تم
إدراكه هنا
هو أن ما تحتاجه في الواقع هو
إطار عمل
الصور التي يتمتع بها المدربون
والخبرة ويمكنك أن تجعل هؤلاء
الشباب في أفضل حالاتك
إنني على يقين من أنه هنا في المملكة
العربية السعودية سيكون لديك فرق كرة قدم تتفوق على العالم ،
وسيكون لديك أبطال جراند سلام
سيكون لديك أفضل الرياضيين
والرياضيين في المستقبل
بسبب ما يحدث هنا
اليوم  رائع ، لذلك أشعر
بالحماس والإثارة في كلماتك التي
تقال ما هو نوع الاتفاقات أو الموسيقي
أو أو
التعاون التي تم توقيعها أو
الحديث عنها هنا في صناعة الرياضة ،
لذلك تم توقيع مذكرة التفاهم
والعلامة التي تم توقيعها اليوم ، وتم توقيع آخر علامة
في عام
1987 وأنت تعلم أن لدينا علاقة أه تاريخية
كدولتين ولكن حان
الوقت للتطلع إلى المستقبل
وخاصة في الرياضة فيما يمكن
تحقيقه في شراكة العمل
وهكذا تعرف أنني قابلت أشخاصًا اليوم
وهناك أشخاص  العمل هنا في
برامج التدريب المشتركة وفي الدعم
لأنك تجلب النساء إلى عالم الرياضة
في كرة القدم هو شيء جديد بالنسبة
للسعودية ولذا من منظور المملكة المتحدة
نريد أن نساعد قدر المستطاع
ونريد أن نعمل شراكة معك
لنرى أنك تعرف أنك تدرك مواهب
ومهارات كل هؤلاء الأشخاص في
جميع المجتمعات في جميع أنحاء المملكة العربية السعودية حتى نتمكن من
رؤية تبادل
للتدريب على التدريب ربما  وبرامج
من هذا النوع ، كل هذه الأشياء في
شراكة رائعة ومتى يمكننا
رؤية ذلك في الحياة ، أعتقد أنه
يحدث الآن ، أعتقد أن الثلاثة
لديهم أكاديمية جديدة هنا
يتم بناؤها ،
ولدينا مدربون هنا في الوقت الحالي
لذلك يحدث بالفعل حديثًا جيدًا عن
الأكاديميات الآن ، دعنا ننتقل إلى الثقافة
لأن الثقافة هي المو الأخرى التي
وقعت عليها في هذه الزيارة ، فما الذي يمكن
أن تقدمه المملكة المتحدة للقطاع الثقافي في
المملكة العربية السعودية لذلك أعتقد
أنه أنت تعرف المساعدة في التدريب
والخبرة على وجه الخصوص في
قطاع الضيافة لأنك تعرف ما إذا
كنت ستذهب إذا كنت بلدًا
يجب على سانجي أن تحافظ على ما هو
تراثها وثقافتها بينما في نفس
الوقت  أنا أعتنق
النوع الثقافي للثورة لجلب
السياحة الترفيهية إلى البلاد
ومن أجل القيام بذلك
تحتاج إلى المهارات التي تحتاجها للتدريب
وتحتاج إلى الخبرة من أولئك الذين
يعملون بالفعل في تلك الصناعات
ونرى ذلك يحدث الآن بشكل جيد
هذا يأخذنا إلى صناعة السياحة ،
أعني أنك قابلت وزير
السياحة وناقشت ربما
عودة السياحة بين
البلدين ، كيف ترى أن هذا
يحدث
حتى إنني سمعت عن  خطط
لملاعب أم رياضية لدور
الأوبرا للموسيقى الكلاسيكية في الهواء الطلق
لقد ذهبت إلى دايا
ورأيت ما يحدث هناك
وسمعت أنني لم أذهب إلى alula ،
سأعود للذهاب إلى لا بد لي من الزيارة
ما أراه يحدث في المملكة العربية السعودية
هو القدرة على الاحتفاظ بالثقافة
والتراث السعودي والبناء
على أساس السياحة القادمة إلى
السعودية وأرى في غضون بضع سنوات وقتًا
للسياح الترفيهيين القادمين إلى
البلاد
حتى لو كانت نيوكاسل.  جميع
المشجعين الذين يأتون لمشاهدة نيوكاسل
يلعبون هنا كمشجع لليفربول
يؤلمني أن أقول ذلك ولكن حتى لو رأينا
أنصار نيوكاسل يأتون للعب هنا
أو رأينا أشخاصًا يأتون لمشاهدة
حفلات موسيقية في الهواء الطلق أو أشخاص يأتون إلى
العروض المسرحية أو الملاعب الرياضية الخاصة بك
أو إلى
مؤسساتك التراثية الضخمة التي يتم
تطويرها هنا ، سيكون هناك أشخاص
يرغبون في زيارة المملكة العربية السعودية سيصبحون
وجهة مفضلة للشعب البريطاني
لقضاء عطلة